starting this month NB energy is Raising
its rates Mary Jane beliesza is live now
with how local customers are concerned
with the change and how you can
potentially save on your energy bill
Mary Jane
well Kirsten this price increase not
only affects residential customers but
consumer customers too several small
businesses reached out to 8 news now
concerned and struggling to stay afloat
as their monthly bill all depends on
energy consumption
between the rising costs of food and gas
and now energy bills Mothership Coffee
Roasters owner wani Romero is feeling
the pinch in her wallet trying to keep
up it's definitely been a struggle
coming out of the pandemic dealing with
a great resignation dealing with as well
as like our employees needs and meeting
them and you're perfectly correct in the
fact that with inflation going up it's
difficult for our staff to provide for
their basic needs and we're doing our
best to meet them NV Energy States the
change is due to the rising costs of
natural gas which is used to fuel the
company's power plants and V Energy says
they also purchased the lowest cost
natural gas available and customers pay
for the natural gas the company uses
Jennifer turchin with the coda group a
sustainability and architect consulting
company advises her commercial clients
to mitigate high costs with energy
saving tips but I think for people that
are already in their buildings
definitely lighting is going to be one
of the easiest ways that people can save
money
um switching to LED from like
incandescent or fluorescent lighting is
a good start and also maybe having like
your equipment service because even
things such as like filters being dirty
can cause inefficiencies in your
equipment Romero is already looking into
ways to cut down on expenses and save
energy but says it isn't as easy as it
looks every light in here is Led
so the minimum amount of wattage we can
take as we move into a new space we
focus on reducing our energy footprint
our carbon footprint
but just for the fact that we live in a
city that's very warm and we have to
keep our products very cold it just
requires a lot of energy to do so
now according to NB Energy's website
this price increase is effective
starting October 1st to December 31st of
this year Mary June bellezza 8 news now
thank you Barry Jade NV Energy does
offer a variety of ways to help its
customers including small businesses
just head to our website at 8newsnow.com
for a list of options to check out